uns jetzt zugeschaltet ist ein mann den
sie alle kennen der bürgermeister von
kiew vitali klitschko hallo witali
schöne grüße nach katt von bevor wir
über joe biden sprechen wollen den mann
den du vitali besonders gut kennst du
hast ihn häufig getroffen
dennoch die frage wie geht es dir du
hattest selbst corona was 14 tage in
quarantäne
genau eine woche und heute endlich mal
akw ergebnis aber was betrieb nehmen zu
wollen und deswegen habe ich hier ein
ergebnis bekommen und alle bürger
gewonnen
immer in den boxen habe ich hier
bürgermeisterwahl gewonnen und ergebnis
schon fast körperlos schon hinter mir
und deswegen deswegen kann ich bin diese
gesund wieder schon im büro
wir haben alle schon bilder gesehen von
dir mit joe biden das war in der zeit
als er vizepräsident war
damals hat er mehrfach in der krise das
land besucht wir erinnern uns alle an
die bilder 2014 von dir auf dem majdan
du bastard oppositionspolitiker hass
gegen präsident janukowitsch gekämpft
und joe biden ist dann 2014/15 als
vizepräsident immer wieder nach kiew
gekommen wie hast du denen man
wahrgenommen der jetzt bald präsident
sein könnte
ja ich mache sagt das vibrieren bringt
auf unseren wiesen wie joe biden war
schon zig mal in eine nehrung sehen
unsere heimatstadt getroffen sich mal
sogar in weitaus offizielle besuch in
washington getroffen gewissen arbeiten
nach hat eine besondere verhältnis vor
einer besonders so kann es schneien
im osten europas sich die geopolitische
opposition hat und so weiter
innovators unterstützer form unsere wand
wie wir alle wissen wegen prostata um
die frage wie schnell diese partner zu
entwickeln
wie stelle ich die unterstützung
politischer unterstützung
wirtschaftliche unterstützung und im
kampf gegen die problematik stets noch
scharf die kam in oslo keine und
annexion bequem und hoffe ich hier
bekommen wir große unterstützung von
neue mögliche neue präsident lula
disneys wieder die abseits vom
politischen was hast du persönlich in
erinnerung wie ist joe biden als mensch
wie war das mit ihm zu sprechen dort
zumeist sehr offen
ein mann mit charisma eine sehr sehr
gute eindruck alle gegeben
meine persönliche meine persönlichen
emotionen an druck gehabt als joe biden
zurück macht für einige staaten an
geflügel betreffe die flugzeugtreppen er
soll recht gelaufen aber gedanken gehabt
ja dann noch mal die dem mann ist in
eine bestimmte alte eine sehr gute form
göttlich und geistig eines topfit da
kann man so eine an druck gemacht und
die wichtigsten ersten buch angesprochen
das bedeutet ich herzlich ein großer
platz zu unserem land
in herzform gemeinden deswegen so halten
wie der präsident wir hoffen auch eine
strategische partnerschaft von amerika
zu bekommen das ist sehr wichtig für
unser heimatland
also wir lernen der ex boxweltmeister
vitali klitschko sagt joe biden ist
topfit vitali abseits davon gab es ja
heftige diskussionen auch um joe biden
und die ukraine
und wenn er präsident werden sollte so
gehen wir davon aus werden diese
diskussion noch weitergehen da geht es
um seinen sohn hunter beiden der dort
bei der firma prisma eine rolle gespielt
hat wie siehst du diese verbindung
kennst du seinen sohn
das wurde ja da in der new york post zum
beispiel scharf kritisiert werden des
wahlkampfs diese verbindung das
handarbeiten dass sein sohn in der
ukraine einen job bekommen hat während
der zeit als joe biden vizepräsident war
ich kenne eben besonders sensor nicht
und diese geschichte wieder sehr
geständig hier ihre ein buch eine gehört
und dass das politikum die abonnenten
verbinden geschäftliche verbindung von
familie zu machen gerüchte auf beweise
klare beweise gerne nicht aber wer das
alles wann regen ja alles wenn alles
funktioniert nur in gesetzlich richtig
richtig
ich sehe keine keine einfluss wären ein
business punkt seien jedoch keine
investition was beträgt indizien aber
gibt sehr viele gerüchte darüber mehr
lange kann ich mir kann ich nicht mehr
sagen wieder lädt zum abschluss du
kennst natürlich nicht nur joe biden
sondern viele staatschefs auf der ganzen
welt und du hast doch häufig schon die
deutsche kanzlerin angela merkel
getroffen was glaubst du wird sie mit
joe biden besser auskommen als mit
donald trump pfalz beiden präsident wird
wie jeder politiker muss
andere wissen dank der formalen ende zu
speichern die weg zu finden
ja ja sag ich wirklich keine sachen
danke schon für angela merkel
bundeskasse wegen die unterstützung
europäischer richtung die entwicklung
von die hochrhein und wir hoffen wir
hoffen dass es wieder drei eine gute
zusammenarbeit zwischen bundeskasse
unter amerikanischer präsident was
betrifft unser heimatland
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren